un bonjour j'ai gagné le gros lot après
avoir payé mes impôts je me suis acheté
un avion pour trouver de nouveaux
[Musique]
horizons àer
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
R
cet avion me revenait très cher une auto
faisait que mon affaire je n'ai pas
hésité une seconde pour partir vers
l'autre bout du
monde ça où ça où ça où ça où ça où ça
et bien à
Moscou
[Musique]
contrairement à ce que l'on a dit en
Russie on peut faire des folies alors
j'ai dû vendre mon auto et je suis parti
sur une
moto ça o o o ça ça et bien
à oh Sacha vieux vous êtes là VI de
faire un chou avec Mariel j'ai fais une
fate de car j'ai fais un Val dans laond
grosse SM
[Applaudissements]
marielôou je serais bien resté mais
l'argent commençait à manquer et me
sparant de ma
moto je suis parti sur un pédal
[Musique]
o
mais
z les
j mon pédal na pas
résisté un bonjour comme simple
Matel je suis parti sur un
[Musique]
vieux
dans les ares bien vra un so que les
ares
éuxar finalement je suis rentré à
pied o ça où ça où ça où ça où ça où ça
où ça où ça o ça et
[Musique]
bien